now Russian President Vladimir Putin has
said that his military campaign in
Ukraine will achieve its quote Noble
objectives he made the remarks as he met
Belarusian President Alexander
lukashenko at a Spaceport in Eastern
Russia to Mark the International Day of
human space flight Putin also claimed
that Russia cannot be isolated from the
world or held back
we know that today our officers are
taking part in a special military
operation in donbass in Ukraine
helping the donbass people's Republics
they are acting bravely professionally
and are effectively using the most
modern weapons that have unique
characteristics
well for more I'm now joined by DW's
Roman gun charenko from DW's Russia
Ukraine and Eastern Europe Department hi
and uh welcome to the program now we
heard President Putin there what do you
make of this and his remarks considering
the atrocities that we've seen committed
in Ukraine
well he made no reference to those
atrocities
um I I would just mention two points one
President Putin appeared to be um
satisfied with how the war is going so
he said everything is wine everything is
going according to the plan
um he made um no no
um no mention of the accusations of a
possible chemical attack in the city of
mariopo which are not confirmed yet but
but there are concerns about that but he
said that Russia was using
um some um very modern weapons we do not
know what he meant the second point is
um he mentioned Dunbar so the Eastern
region of Ukraine saying that that was
one of the objectives of this war and
this is something I think which points
out
in the direction of a possible offensive
a new Russian offensive that we will see
in the coming days or weeks and because
everybody's talking about it and he
tried probably to cover up the the
um
the the problems the Russian army
encountered around Kiev in the north of
Ukraine so now forces are concentrated
in the east
Roman do we know how the Russian public
is reacting to the war
well there is not much reaction that we
can see because
um most Russian opposition leaders are
abroad in prison or one of them Vladimir
karamoza was detained on Monday so
nothing there we see less less protests
of citizens in in Russian cities we've
seen some in in the beginning of this
war but we see less and less of that so
there are more and more oppressions
against opposition or against those who
oppose this war and all polls show that
up to three fourths more than 60 or 70
percent of the Russian populations
support this war actually so there is no
much protest to be seen if there is any
people hold it for themselves talk about
it in private not openly
Roman you've mentioned it just before
you were talking about the donbass and
how President Putin mentioned it but do
we have any indication of what lies
ahead
well I think that everybody is talking
about a possible new escalation in the
East I think this is the case
um but I think we might see also some
surprises because because there are some
crucial dates coming up the 9th of May
the Day of Victory of Soviet Union over
Nazi Germany and of course Putin and
Russia would like to celebrate it with
some kind of Victory I think surprises
us are also possible in other regions
for example in the south of Ukraine so
in short I think an escalation is coming
how big we will see
tw's Roman goncharenko thank you